There are many people who
misunderstand what fiction is.
They'll say, "Fiction
is a bunch of lies."
I would say fiction is
actually one of the best
ways for finding truth.
When I started writing
"The Joy Luck Club,"
I was such a novice.
There was so much I
didn't know about writing.
As you ask yourself,
"What do I have
in my life to write about?"--
Believe me, you have plenty.
In this class, I'm
going to give you
guideposts-- examples of
things that worked and also
didn't work.
I'm going to show you
rejection letters.
the tools you already
have at your disposal,
which is your own thoughts,
your own memory, and your
own form of imagination.
You can use your past as
the tool of your trade;
and me, the writer, is
saying, "This is good."
It's bad when it happened.
Me, the writer-- "This is
good," because what I can do
now is take that visceral
sensation, and I can use it.
"My father has asked me to be
the fourth corner at the Joy
Luck Club.
I am to replace my mother,
whose seat at the mahjong table
has been empty since
she died two months ago.
My father thinks she was
killed by her own thoughts."
Imbalance, crisis--
that moves you forward.
You don't have to have
trauma to be a writer.
What you need to
have is perspective.
If you have a seriousness
of purpose, which
is to understand yourself,
human nature, the world,
and the conflicts that make
us infinitely interesting,
you will find the stories
that you want to tell.
I'm Amy Tan, and this
is my MasterClass.